a shot to the heart by a man with a
homemade gun
a routine campaign speech ending in an
unprecedented assassination
former japanese prime minister shinzo
abe died friday morning in the western
city of nara he was campaigning for
upper house elections scheduled for
sunday
seconds after abe collapsed officers
tackled the suspect
police say 41 year old tatsuya yamagami
told them he was disgruntled with abe
and aimed to kill him
it was a rare occurrence in a country
with a low crime rate and some of the
world's most restrictive gun laws
we cannot accept that this violent act
took place during an election
the foundation of democracy
in the strongest terms i condemn this
attack
the 67 year old was a dynamo of japanese
politics and a third generation
politician
his grandfather was prime minister his
father foreign minister
abe distinguished himself as the
longest-serving prime minister with two
terms in office
he brought stability to a political
system that tended to kind of churn out
prime ministers one after another
not only that but he was also
transformative in japanese politics he
made japan a much more significant
player in terms of regional and i would
say even global security
abe promoted policies dubbed ubenomics
intended to boost the economy
he wanted to strengthen japan's
geopolitical clout by amending its
post-world war ii pacifist constitution
it proved polarizing among the public
and his efforts failed
during his last year in office he was
criticized for his handling of the kovit
19 pandemic
worked hard every single day to
revitalize the economy and to conduct
diplomacy that would protect the
national interest
during this time i'm proud to have taken
on various challenges with the japanese
people
although he resigned in 2020 citing poor
health the following year abe returned
as leader of the liberal democratic
party a man who couldn't shed his
political skin
assassinated for it natasha name al
jazeera